we're off to take a wonderful walk with
Maddie by the beach he loves to go
outside so much we also love to go
outside and we love Maddie so let's go
for a walk
where's my keys his favorite color is
definitely pink because it is it looks
so good on them what are we gonna listen
to what is this a fire hose that is a
fifty-foot this is a fire hose it's a
15-foot
over here the marine odd it is a
beautiful day Maddie is not interested
in any of the treats that I brought so
basically we are having zero success on
getting him to listen and that's not
good we've got his big long leash
Jenna's got my ear but Ma Tei Maddie is
a wild one
hey I heard Maddie was of Oh Oh Maddie
he does not with his cheese that's not
good
Oh
somebody's extremely exhausted let's see
to Bali let's see the Bali Oh sleepy boy
right Madi we gotta hop back in the car
we got to get back to your crib this
your mouth let's see you sailor my
jealousy late at the party yeah shut the
up have a party
so I was just sitting here editing and I
was talking about having a party and
guess what I didn't film I felt nothing
from the party but I did do a live
stream on my Facebook's if you actually
want to go check that out there's two
live streams facebook.com slash iJustine
you're watching these red carpet
coverage and Maddie and show them your
tie and now I'm just gonna share my
snapchat story that I filmed this was my
legit reaction to Leonardo DiCaprio
winning an Oscar I didn't watch much of
the Oscars I watched basically the end
part holy moly Congrats leo so where is
my snapchat reaction to Leonardo
DiCaprio winning an Oscar is it gonna be
is it gonna be Liam are you nervous God
me I'm ready to tweet and everything
so that my friends was my reaction
Congrats akin to Leo Congrats to
everyone who won an award tonight
although I hardly have seen any of the
movies that were nominated or anything
that really won so I'm a little bit
behind anyway I'm gonna go to bed it's
extremely late so hopefully I'll see you
guys tomorrow that's all I've got today
beats out and in stop the camera
there's fell asleep hey guys how's it
going so we've been chatting a lot about
the iphone 7 rumors and I got a really
great response from you guys as far as
what you thought about the headphone
jack